to get a better handle off how is qbe a
visual way of retrieving data
let me show you an example and you can
pull one up as well let's go to google
morning
um now
what hilarious okay
so if you go to google right um put in a
put in a search term any search term you
like
and where i want to draw your attention
to is up at this um this gear icon at
the top right
okay because under there is something
very very
handy for us which from memory used to
be on the google front page
but one of the things about google is
they're trying to make their designs as
minimalist as possible
hiding away features that most people
don't use what i'm after
is advanced search okay
now if i if i come back over here what
you are looking at right now let me see
if i can make this a bit bigger for you
what you are looking at right now is a
very
simple example of query by example
okay simple example of query by example
what does it mean
uh you're searching a big relational
database
when you search on google every single
time you're not actually searching the
internet
you're searching google's database about
the internet
okay but how do you how do you go about
searching for things well you could just
put in that search term and let google
do all the work
or you could be a little more specific
and you could break it down in these
kinds of ways okay
now can you see how this is far more
visual
than this okay this is kind of like a
what we would call a command line
interface
kind of the point is that if you want
the computer to do something
you have to type up instructions and and
hand it over to the computer and say
do this do that it's kind of like a
recipe if you like okay
whereas when you look at this this is
more like filling out a form
okay and it's called query by example
because the things that you put into the
things you
fill out the form with are examples of
what you're looking for
these are all about um you know search
terms and that kind of thing but if you
go further down
you know for instance have a look at
this
can you see how this really streamlines
the way
that search and retrieving data works
because
for instance language region last update
um reading level all these kinds of
things they're going to be
attributes of the different records
in your database right and because
there's only a finite number of options
for this right it makes sense to put it
out in a list there for you
you can choose from a menu okay can you
see how this is far more visual than
actually
typing in where language equals
or belarus or whatever
okay this is a far more visual approach
to it
so here's an example and later on i'm
going to ask you guys to find your own
example but can you see how
essentially what it's doing is allowing
us to
search your database in a visual way and
often it's actually called
filtering right uh filtering is kind of
like a
parallel term for it because you're
looking at this data and you're trying
to limit restrict it based on examples
that you give
the database
okay so i think i've sort of described
why did they go about developing this
when sql was around here's an example
and i've shown you how the visualness of
it makes it very much
quicker easier to search through the
data okay
it also takes the guesswork out of you
know
up here you can only really construct
this query
if you already have intimate knowledge
of what the database is like and how
it's structured
okay you've got to know the names of the
tables and you've got to know the names
of the attributes and be able to
construct something like this
whereas um you might not have known
beforehand that all of these are the
attributes that you can search for in
the big database okay
but query by example it tells you what
they are okay
so uh you don't need to know that
database well to be able to search
through it
okay it sort of holds your hand through
it if you like